concert promoter danny zolisko has
produced and promoted more than 10
000 concerts and has put his rock n roll
tales in a new book called all
excess occupation concert promoter check
it out
danny thank you so much for joining us
they say you can't judge a book by its
cover
but i beg to differ when it comes to
your book because please tell me what's
going on in the picture of your book
well that's the cover of the book in
1988
i did a couple of shows on the pink
floyd momentary lapse of reason
tour we were in the phoenix municipal
stadium that held
about 25 000 people for the show but for
baseball
there was only 8 000 capacity so they
only had parking for eight thousand
so i my security guy very wisely came to
me
and said give me ten thousand dollars i
go what for he goes
i'm gonna go rent all the parking lots
around the stadium
and we'll charge ten bucks a car and and
it's all your money
you know and i ended up making more
money on the parking than i did on the
show
give everyone kind of the tagline the
byline description of what a concert
promoter
uh what a concert producer does well
you know you you've got to be on their
call sheet the agent's call sheet to
begin with um
you've got to be in a city um that
that has good venues to put on shows
whether they're clubs or auditoriums or
arenas
and you you call up and you make deals
to present these artists in public and
you've done over 10 000 concerts and
there's so many i want to talk to you
about the one i want to start off with
though
is right here in las vegas silver bowl
sam boyd stadium
grateful dead back in 1995 you and jerry
garcia
you he had kind of an interesting demand
that you fulfilled for him what was it
um jerry wanted to go see the tigers
the siegfried and roy tigers so um
jason uh who was working for laura
herlovich at the time
um took him uh at my request to see
the tigers and and he got jerry got to
meet the tigers after the show you've
had an impact here in the city of las
vegas because
i think when it comes to entertainment
when you think of las vegas you think of
frank sinatra
dean martin the rat pack elvis and then
the early 80s i think 1983
thomas and mack opens up you step in and
start booking these concerts
and that kind of changed the landscape
of entertainment what were some of those
early concerts you were booking at the
thomas and rack
we've done there's so many great shows
there you two
billy joel um metallica
whitney houston one of one of the
greatest shows ever i had in there
was her does mike tyson still live in
vegas
oh yeah yeah i hope he hears this i hope
that right there
so we whitney was at the show and
there's a group i think was called take
six opening the show so during their set
the road manager whitney comes back and
says miss houston would like to see you
she's screaming mike tyson's on my stage
you get his offer there right now
you know she goes out she goes i want
you to go up there and lead him
off the stage he's creating havoc on the
stage and she's going
i wouldn't go into his ring and start
singing
you know so i had to go there and he had
a couple of giant bodyguards and he goes
let him through
and and i explained to him what's
happened i said you're blowing a man
she's not going to come on stage till
you get off the stage
and i have to walk you down the stage
don't hit me
and he goes all right i understand he
walked off the stage replaces bullying
and cheering and
whatever and as we hit the bottom step
boom the lights went out and she's on
stage singing
and she's just laughing at me he's got
so many great stories you can get
danny's book all
xs occupation concert promoter online at
amazon.com
and las vegas now we'll be